by the end of today more than one and a
half million people in Virginia and the
Carolinas will be under evacuation
orders now this affects a huge area
along the coast mandatory evacuation
orders took effect in North Carolina at
7 a.m.
covering more than 100 miles of
shoreline in the path of the storm
mark Strassmann is right there on the
coast in Kitty Hawk mark good morning
good morning this area knows hurricanes
for instance take the Kitty Hawk pier
behind me it's about half the size it
was in 2003 when Hurricane Isabel
knocked the rest of it into the Atlantic
now late last night President Trump
issued a federal disaster declaration
that's to make sure resources will be
ready when the storm makes landfall here
as early as Friday morning an estimated
50,000 residents and visitors have been
evacuated from Cape Hatteras about 40
miles south of here as we headed here
last night there was a steady flow of
cars heading north people leaving the
area
heavy equipment was also out building
massive sand dunes as a wall of defense
against the storm surge that's expected
up and down the coast North Carolina's
governor Roy Cooper called the surge
along with the winds and the island
flooding the three critical threats this
state faces from Hurricane Florence
officials with the National Hurricane
Center's warn Florence is expected to
linger over the Carolinas once it makes
landfall that increases the threat of
major flooding from miles inland along
with a possibility of widespread power
outages we are now officially under a
hurricane watch here as of a couple of
hours ago emergency officials said they
started evacuating asking people to
leave and then ordering people to leave
over the last couple of days that's
because they say if they waited until
the last minute until the declaration
was in place they would not have enough
time to get everyone out John all right
mark thank you